And that's why she's online right now doing all this goofy ass
is because she needs the whole internet to agree with her. She
will not stop. She will keep going. >> Uh this is not good.
Uh this is not good. >> Cuz none of her other exes would
entertain putting a dog collar on her and walking around like
a good old >> Dude, he's going to start dumping all of
her fetishes and [__] I hope this is where he's like
just kidding. Of course I wouldn't do that cuz I'm an adult and
I would never do that to another person.
>> We have
the Abba stream and she did a stream
This is This was yet crazy yesterday. The Libertine girl, she
went on the Saint and the Sinner, Marquetta Von Burton. She went
on that stream to trash Abba to this guy, okay? Got really
Um this guy was asking about how many fingers Abba loves to show
loves to have shoved up his ass. It was very off-putting. This
guy's got a weird energy to him, okay? Apparently, Abba is going
to feel vindicated after this.
Let's give it a look. All right, let's get to it. So, um folks
have been asking a million questions and uh I just want to kind
of go through a couple things bullet points and just blah blah
blah blah blah. I don't want to spend too much time cuz again,
I do feel like this is pretty juvenile, but uh I know she wants
to drag it there, so we got to go.
Ooh, take me through that. Take me through that. [__]
mhm mhm
That's a little weird, preach. >> you who didn't catch
the first one or the first live we did, um essentially there's
some allegations that I was like a deadbeat or I didn't want
to be part
you know some kid and I forced her to have an abortion and turned
out that none of that was true that I uh tried my best and I
was the only one out of the two of us who wanted to keep the
>> while we were in a relationship
and uh she kept changing her mind dozens of times, scheduled
multiple abortion appointments that I was against but still supported
her through and uh she would reneg every time.
And then come to the end of the relationship, she decided that
she was not only going to end the relationship, but she wanted
to keep the child. All of a sudden, she wanted to start co-parenting
and doing stuff like that. From my perspective, I got my own
thoughts and all that. But yeah, we covered a lot of that in
the first one. Uh we covered quite a lot of the other stuff,
but since then there's quite a bit of stuff that she's put out,
including her blackmail material, the stuff that she's recorded
me on. Um so I figured it'd be a good time to start to go through
some of the things that she's been alleging, all right? But yes,
>> I've heard he's got to get really,
really specific about some very uncomfortable [__]
in this. I don't know I don't know if I'm going to enjoy it.
It might be a little weird. Things might get weird. >> She's
a nurse out of California.
I think she's from Orange County, but she's been working out
of San Jose. She worked at the Kaiser Permanente as a full-time
Um and a lot of people hit me up since and they're like, "Don't
date nurses." Hey, listen, you know what? That's one of them
stereotypes I didn't really uh buy into too hard. >> Oh,
you you was ready to believe the military stereotype, not the
nurse >> Dude, literally, he must have just gotten overwhelmed,
like totally inundated with that same comment of like, "Bro,
how many red flags you need, bro? How many red flags you need,
man?"
The good lord tried to save you. The good lord threw up threw
out so many red flags for you, and you were just like, "Nah,
nah, you're color blind now." >> I know. >> That's
a green flag. That's a green flag. That's a She's a nurse, she
cares about people. >> Cuz I believe in military stuff.
I mean, that's pretty fair, you know? Sure. Just >> To
be fair, if you need somebody who's going to be willing
to put stuff in your ass,
then a nurse is probably a good place to start, right? >> When
she told me she was going to do any of this stuff like way back,
I was like, "You know you're going to embarrass yourself, right?"
And she doesn't care. And you might be thinking, "Well, what
does she have to gain?" Obviously, there must be something. And
I'm going to play you guys a short clip. This is a short clip.
But this is really encapsulating everything about her even in
our dynamic, okay? This is a short clip, but like I play this
because this moment is when she was recording me, right? She
was recording me at my lowest. And she has this clip here. And
at one point in this conversation she says something.
>> NO, CUZ I LOOK >> THIS IS ANOTHER THING. THIS
IS ANOTHER THING I pointed out that when
like when she's recording this, she's like obviously egging him
on to say more >> Tell me all the things you hate about
me. Tell me everything I've ever done bad. Tell me all the things
you hate about me right now. >> Like, dude, how did you
not know you were being recorded? Are you serious? >> So,
at this point we're having this conversation. This is like she
just betrayed me big time, okay? She put me in the dumps literally
24 hours before. She gave me the news. [__] me up
for a day for a little while, and then she's harassing the [__]
out of me. I didn't want to talk to her. I wanted space. She
didn't care about my boundaries. She was harassing. From her
end she's going to say, "Oh, I want to talk about Cole Barter
in mind." I'm like, "I don't think that's what it is." But, she's
recording and during our argument, I just want to imagine you
guys in a relationship with someone and they say stuff like this
all the time, okay? Let's listen to what she says here. >> But,
I did everything right. I did everything right, Abbott, and you
know it.
>> Now, everything. Why you talking to me, >> No.
No. No. No. No. >> The reason why I played that clip is
to get you guys in the idea of why she's doing any of this. People
like, "It's for money. It's for a lawsuit." It's No. Okay, you
guys are going to start to see what I dealt with when I dated
this person. It's that
>> She's like I'm sorry.
I should be very clear.
I I should have seen this.
The only way you come back so hard on a woman with that Instagram
profile being there is if she's also gone extremely hard at you.
Like, if you've been like pushed on something. I don't think
you get that emotional
when you find out this person lied to you if you don't have like
some whole thing where you were like basically holding back.
You didn't have like resentment cuz you were holding back how
angry you were about other stuff or how you felt mistreated.
I think that's the only way you explain that that like coming
back that hard over the >> She really believes that she
is always right. Even [snorts] when she's in 4K >> No.
No, hold on. Dirty is you're saying, "Oh, well, she already said
she made him unfollow people." Or he already said she made him
delete all the girls. No, it was two or one or something. And
also, that wouldn't be enough. That's not even crazy.
Dude, you just you just do that in relationships. If your partner
has like some sort of insecurity, you would just do that. Why
not?
It but that wouldn't be what it was. It was like something way,
way, way heavier than that. Which I guess we're going to find
out. >> And so, when she put out her content and I never
even replied and everyone was flaming her everywhere, including
people who hate me, the reason why is because she looks crazy,
right? But it doesn't matter to her because in her head
she did everything right. She did everything right and she needs
everyone to know, okay? So, let's go through some of the many
lies she told and then we can just showcase some of it. So, she
did an interview with Stevie Knight and you know Stevie, ever
since I exposed the fact that he didn't get school lunches in
the third grade, Stevie, like a good old dog, saw a bone and
he bit. >> And let's take a listen to this interview with
him. >> Dude, one of the first He's explaining all the
bad things about her, right?
Alba, this begs a GREAT QUESTION. WHY DID YOU DATE HER? YEAH?
YEAH, that's pretty smart, yeah. >> full-blown investigation
on Alba. So, have you been plotting on her the whole time like
>> I wasn't planning this for a long time. The catalyst
to me wanting to come out >> Her internet's really bad
and so that's why it's a bit out of sync. >> But I can't
say [__] cuz my internet was bad too on my channel.
So, my my bad. Fair. So, you know what? It is what it >> So,
he's asking her, what was the catalyst? Like when did this all
start, this investigation, this kind of like exposé thing, right?
Listen to what she
>> Okay, so you heard what she said? She said April. >> I
wasn't planning this for a long time. The catalyst
>> Uh okay.
I see where he's going to go. I see it. >> to me wanting
to come out was April. >> No. We ended our relationship
in January, the night she broke up with me. After that point,
I haven't seen her since January 2nd. She wanted to, but I haven't
seen her since then. I want you guys to pay attention to what
I'm about to put >> You crashed the [__] out.
This is okay, am I the only person who's going to check him on
his too?
He crashed the [__] out over Instagram posts in February,
Alba. They were in
You weren't together anymore by your own admission. So, you're
telling me that emotional
that's totally insane emotional rant you went on was over Instagram
post when you were no longer
You understand that makes you a thousand times worse? Like not
then her but then what I thought before.
If you weren't trying to get back together, if you weren't No,
she was not cheating. She was posting on Instagram.
That's crazy. That's Okay, maybe we'll get more context. Let
me keep going. >> She says April is when she started this
whole thing. Come to find out All right, look at this right here.
It says, "Hi, I'm contacting you on behalf of my friend who's
dating Ava. She wanted to know she meaning my girl Liberty in
here if she >> Oh wait, that's actually a good point though
Whisper in the Dark. Yeah, I didn't understand what you're saying
what you're getting at. He says he called her a cheater because
of her behavior in February when they weren't together apparently.
He needs to get He needs to get his story straight, man. That's
a shameful. >> So let's go to the next slide. She's crazy
in the streets. Let's go to the next slide. Right here.
Okay, let's see what this next >> And then even in the
phone call, you just hear him saying like I'm harassing him.
I'm stalking and I'm a crazy stalker. That's how he >> So
so basically all the all the harassment he's referring to happened
within two days. >> Yeah, it >> Two days. So she's
claiming that only in January 12th in that area around is the
time that she would harass me, do all this crazy stuff where
she would hit me up from random numbers or go crazy. And I just
want y'all to see, all right? Cuz I have to start digging. I'm
I'm going to have the kill shot later. Don't worry, it's coming.
But let's just listen to some more lies. It only happened within
two days. Let's find >> I need him to provide proof for
that. >> Okay, so All right, we need to go back and I missed
that up.
>> I need him to provide proof for that. >> Okay,
2025. So we're not even in January. That's how you know she's
lying. Watch this. Watch this. It's all from her. All from her.
And you guys know I have to say I called the police. This is
one of the other attempts. Yeah, like this is 2026 02. That's
February. Is this still January? We're going to keep going through
all of these. This is recently. This girl that made new accounts
into this day as recently as two days ago. She's making new Instagram
accounts liking every image so that I will go and try to contact
her. So you need to understand, she's been harassing the [__]
out of me and stalking me. For instance, I'll get to the blackmail.
I'll get to the smoking guns later. But I'm just trying to establish
how crazy and how long it's been and how I've said nothing about
most of this behavior publicly because this is just embarrassing.
Let's move Okay? This is all her. You see Libertine? Crazy. This
is Okay, I didn't know this, but apparently when people make
an Insta like an Instagram from a Gmail account,
When you block them and they delete the account, it looks like
this. So, this is one of her many accounts.
>> She has made a lot. She's made a lot of >> All right,
these are all the accounts I've had to block from her where she's
contacting me from.
And we're going to go through the She has a lot of Instagrams,
a lot of different ones. This is another one.
>> Bro, every time Abba starts talking about more of the
Instagrams, these Instagrams are all findable with her name,
by the way. Like Like
Tom Bronson went and looked for these Instagrams. He found like
85 of them. He was like, "Dude, it was like a full page of just
her on Instagram." And like they're all Instagrams with like
slightly different purposes.
So, when he says, "Oh, I had no idea she was making an Instagram
like this." I do feel like he's he's capping a bit. >> These are
some of the phone numbers,
So, I just need to make it clear. This is not even the tip of
the iceberg. I started deleting so many text messages. I don't
know what kind of hack she has where she can just generate a
new phone number, but like she would create them faster than
I could block them. And they would be flooding in. Now, you might
say, "Well, Abba, why did you ever reply to anything?" It started
to get to me when it replied to other people around me. You know,
my thing is if it's directed towards me, it's easy to kind of
ignore, but when it starts to involve my business, when it starts
to message Preach, when it starts to message the others around
me and stuff like that, then I have a different response cuz
now I feel like I'm involving them and I'm not protecting them,
okay? Not the best response. Still doesn't mean I shouldn't engage,
but I hope you guys understand just how extensive the harassment
has been from this individual. All right. So, we're going to
move I mean, you guys saw all this stuff. This was from the two
days she mentioned, right? This is where she threatened to blackmail
me with talking to Myron or whatever, okay? We're going to move
past that. So, this whole saga is going on, okay?
I want to move to
another section real fast. Let's see here. Let's see. Okay.
So, at this point, there's this other narrative here and I'm
going to Let the clip play now, actually.
>> I mean, you said in the mission that you wanted the
baby. But so, you really had him on this like, you know, seesaw
effect like you do or you don't have this baby, you never had
this baby. So, I can imagine the emotional toll on, bro. So,
why the flip-flop so much?
>> Yeah, I honestly empathize with him. I get doing back
and forth because
I saw Abba how I did see how much Abba was wanting the baby and
I empathize with that.
Yeah, I mean, so everyone agrees. Yeah, except her. No, she's
Wait. No, go ahead. Except her what? No, tell her
Cuz she's claimed a couple of times that you left her. You implying
that you didn't want that >> She said that. >> She
said a lot of things. >> They have to make her they look
really >> Yeah, they like need her to be even more of a
liar. Like she's lied about some stuff. She is emotional. She
is like kind of crazy in how she's going about this. But like
they have to make her look a hundred times worse than she already
does to make it make sense that he lost his mind like this, right?
>> So, what comes after this portion? Cuz we need to get
to the good stuff. And don't worry, it's going to get good. Now,
we get into the idea that Abba has an anger issue. He does his
yelling and verbal abuse and all this other stuff. And every
time I heard her, I would be like, "What are you smoking?" And
then she told the story I remember. And I knew it didn't go the
way she said. But let's listen to her tell the story. And I want
you guys to listen to this in its
>> And then another comment about like girls being hot
in Spain and just something like that. And >> Backdrop,
she's at my place is the final time we see each other around
New Year's, okay? We're sitting around having breakfast. And
this is what she's referring to. I'm going to let her tell the
story and then I'll add in the >> Why does she keep calling
Montreal Spain, by the way? How do you even How do you even make
that like conflation? Doesn't make any sense. >> hot the
other girls were in front of >> Yeah, he was like, "I went
to Spain and like Spain has the hottest people." And he was like,
"The women in Spain are like really hot." And we had talked about
this before and he said stuff like this. And then I get upset
and then I leave the house. And and then I come back. But I I
do pack my things cuz I'm like, "I'm going to go somewhere else."
But I do come back. And I was just like a little angry so I left
the coffee shop and stuff. I do come back. And he gets so upset
with me. We start fighting >> What do you mean you left
the coffee >> Because I left, yeah. And he got so upset.
And I was trying to explain to him why I was upset. And he just
wouldn't hear it. He didn't understand [clears throat] why I
was
>> Yeah, I I'm sorry. I can listen to this without the
faces that he's making and see that this is like I just left
and then he was so upset that I just left.
Yeah, nobody is like that. That's not how anybody is. I just
left and then he was like so mad that I just left.
Uh-huh. Or did you guys like have a fight? Right? You were leaving.
You said some crazy [__] on the way out. And then
you came back you had another fight cuz you said some crazy [__]
on the way out. >> I was upset or mad, things would escalate
and I'm trying to explain it to him he's like no you left, you
need to get out of the house and I'm trying to tell him like
why don't you see why I left in the first place and um and then
it would boil up and then I start crying and then um and then
he does the whole mocking and yelling and screaming thing and
I know that's hard to to imagine but like just for a minute >> it's
hard to imagine because you're not saying [__] that
is very concrete. She said I was I was yelling yes I understand
I was screaming I understand but she's leaving out the way she
is telling the story there's a lot of things that she leave out.
The story is not very precise. Like someone that You know what
I'm not going to say someone. I'm telling a story I was right.
I'm telling you I listen we were talking about this we were talking
about that and then he said this he said that then I was upset
because you're explaining stuff she's not really explaining okay
you listen. >> whole mocking and yelling and screaming
thing and I know that's hard to to imagine but like just for
a minute >> It's hard to imagine I got a phone call so
all right so she believes I was screaming and yelling and being
verbally >> Yeah so the phone call is just like a preview
to what I experienced a lot with him personally. It didn't feel
right it didn't feel safe. He would yell he would scream. I was
pregnant in Montreal he kicked me out. He has his reasons for
it. I was pregnant I had no signal outside I was outside the
apartment and trying to get a ride >> Okay you guys heard
her right. So I'm going to give you guys a context to the argument
the argument wasn't that big it was basically she's like >> This
is like the precise
kind of stream. I'm guessing I've been told that he like does
really well in this stream this is the smoking gun.
Oh this is so stupid. There's no way this convinces people of
like oh she's all in the wrong and he's all in the
Unless this takes like a insane turn. This has to take a totally
totally insane turn.
Because right now he's going well yeah we had this huge fight
and she's like telling it as if she did nothing wrong. Yeah that's
how everybody tells a story man. I don't I don't know what to
tell
I okay. >> She she makes it sound like I was like man these
[__] women are being so >> He just looks mad.
Everybody here looks >> It wasn't that what happened. We
were talking about people attractive in different places you
know in some places you'll find the men more attractive in some
places you'll find the women more attractive. Me and her had
this conversation dozens of times. Where we'd be like oh the
women here are more attractive the men there I think have their
style whatever fair fair. So we were having this and we were
talking about the dudes in the west coast whatever it is and
then I mentioned and she she got upset. Of course you don't that
conversation with your girl. That's her bag. She got upset about
that, okay?
>> That's so funny, man. Preach.
>> God forbid, she throws a tantrum. >> Of course,
she got upset. You don't have that conversation with your woman.
>> I have that conversation with her. So, we were having
this and we were talking about the dudes in the West Coast, whatever
it is. And then I mentioned it and she she got upset. Of course,
you don't have that conversation with your That's her bag. She
got upset about that, okay? >> Got him. >> God forbid,
she throws a tantrum. When she gets upset, I just give her space.
So, that's what she needs, so that's how we settle things up.
I respect it. I go to the room. A little time goes by. I go outside.
She's gone.
I don't look for her. >> Wait, do you give her space and
then do you reflect on why you were fighting and see if you did
something wrong? Or do you give her space like in the way I've
I give people space is like we got into a fight and I'm going
to go do something else that takes my mind off of it entirely
and I'm not even going to think about why we just fought or why
we had an argument. Cuz I know that's the most toxic kind of
giving space where you like walk away and you don't think about
the argument you had, you don't think about why you were fighting.
You just walk away and like play video games or something. That's
like the worst kind of That's not really space, right? That's
like an evasion. That's like avoiding the conversation entirely.
So, he says he Yeah, I do know it's the toxic one. And everybody
does this and it's like, dude, being the nonchalant person is
not proof that you were like in the right. >> It's just
fine. >> And then I realized she packed her bags and took
it with her. She packed her bags. So, for a minor argument on
the final day that we were spending time after she's just traveled
a good 9 hours to be here, over a minor argument, she packed
her bags and she
Was I upset? Absolutely. She claims that when she came back,
I was upset cuz she left. I don't care you left. I think it's
normal when you argue and you want to take a walk.
>> Uh
yeah. Yeah.
Wait, did she say She said she packed her bags, right? Like you
can read into that. I understand she's misrepresenting it, but
like I'm sorry, just I can't be the only person who like looks
at that and it's just like, oh, you're emotional, it was a breakup,
you can't see what you did wrong, but I can hear you telling
the events and I can see what you did wrong and I understand
how you can interpret it away, but I don't really care. It's
like if they don't factually distort things, I'm not usually
that concerned about like them reframing to make themselves seem
like they're the victim only. Especially in like a breakup, something
super emotional like this. I just don't really penalize the person
telling the story that much.
>> I take her space. Packing the bags to me, especially
knowing how I like to set up these were like, we can always figure
this out. So, don't walk out on me. Don't quit. We can figure
it out. Her packing the bags was a bit harsh for me.
She comes back. Understandable. Is she >> By the way, totally
understandable that he would be upset about it. Right? It's totally
understandable that when she comes back, he's like livid that
he's got her there and she immediately packs her bag over like
this stupid fight and leaves. It's okay for him to be upset about
that. >> Make a comment to me and he goes, "I want to show
the comments actually cuz you guys will find out." So, now she's
claiming I was screaming, I was yelling. I was verbally abusive
and then I kicked her out and I left her outside as a pregnant
woman in the Montreal cold. Right? She went outside. I said,
"Get out of here." And I said,
>> I didn't take you out that way.
>> Now, here's what's crazy. I didn't realize this, but
I actually had recorded
that interaction.
>> Wait, when is that interaction?
Wait, when is that interaction? Wait, when did she go to Montreal?
Dude, I'm sorry. I'm getting the I'm getting New Year's. I'm
getting the weirdest vibes. I'm getting the weirdest vibes. I'm
getting the weirdest vibes. I'm so sorry. Oh, I had no idea.
I actually record How did you record it? Did you accidentally
like elbow your phone and it turned on? Bro, what?
>> I forgot.
The reason why is that when I get somebody out of my house, just
so there's no craziness or they can't say later, sometimes I
do You know what I mean? And you might think it's a lot, but
it's safe to me. >> Dude, I am so sorry. I Man, oh, I think
smartphones might have killed like the average relationship.
I think it's like over. I think it's completely over. The fact
that you can like record in in a like hidden way, the fact that
all this can happen, man. It's like it it just leads to people
taking down all the evidence they can and running the relationship
like a like a consistent game where they're going to keep track
of every wrongdoing the other person knowing that eventually
if they break up they can win the breakup.
It's so sad.
I'll I'll just lose, man. Like just lose. I'll just lose. I don't
care. I'll just lose.
You won. Bye. >> I want you guys to listen to this. >> You
know what I mean? Like I just don't get I Like I say this all
the time. I say it all the time.
I ever had to record somebody to deal with them,
I would just leave the relationship. I'm never doing that.
No reason. Unless they said that like unless I incredibly thought
they were like trying to
do some like unless I knew that they were committing a crime
and I could somehow do it like I'm trying to think I've never
done it, but if they were like explaining to me how they were
extorting me and they had like my family held hostage. Like there's
going to be a situation.
You know what I mean?
But like I it's just never happened. I've never I can't even
conceive of it happening.
>> the interaction where I was screaming and yelling.
And personally, it didn't feel right. It didn't feel safe. He
would yell. He would scream. I was pregnant in Montreal. He kicked
me out. He has his reason for it. I was pregnant. I had no signal
outside. I was locked out of the apartment in Canada weather.
And then it would pile up and then I start crying. And then he
does the whole man yelling and screaming thing and
>> Did you try to book a Put in his going to get coffee.
So, what happened? You booked a hotel and your phone didn't work,
that's why you came back? >> My phone didn't work down
there. >> Right. So, she came back and she says I'm like
where were you? And she's like I only came back cuz I didn't
have any cell service, but I wanted to book my own place. So,
not only did she just disappear like this, when she came back
she kept acting weird. And at this point she starts talking about
it doesn't feel safe. So, me, a woman says anything like that,
that's a wrap. You don't feel safe in my home? I'm not going
to keep you here. Especially you're a tiny woman, I'm a black
dude, I ain't playing that >> So, because you couldn't
book a hotel with your phone, now you want to stay >> I
didn't want to go. >> I didn't want to go. Yeah, you can
leave. You were trying to book a hotel, now you come back pretending
like you didn't want to go. So, I don't need to leave. If you
want to leave, leave. Absolutely, actually. Let me book it for
you you tripping
This is this is me yelling keep in mind I'm close to the mic
and I have to boost the audio because her voice is so low so
if you think this sounds a lot louder it's because I boosted
it as much as I could so I could hear her you couldn't get cell
service oh hell no So I'm going to book it for you but you told
me you wanted to go now you want to stay here >> You don't
want to go >> I do want to go you quit and you trying to
book a hotel now you coming back pretending like you didn't want
to go so I don't need that [__] leave if you want
to leave leave absolutely actually let me book it for you you
tripping [__] you sitting here just because you couldn't
get cell service oh hell no so I'm going to book it for you I'll
pay for the Uber and everything I'll make it super easy
>> But I don't want to >> Exactly so now you don't
need the cell service I'm going to book it for you let me know
when the yelling stops you're tripping I can send her a receipt
now >> Let me know when the yelling starts
>> So yeah she's obviously miss she's miss represented
this
I he's obviously okay he's obviously mad but not the kind of
mad she represented it as and I don't think this is an unreasonable
reaction to be this mad I haven't heard the thing about safety
I'm wondering when he started recording did he record as soon
as she got back
>> Don't forget this is her evidence of verbal abuse listen
to it listen to it okay so you guys didn't hear this but I'm
going to just play it back at one point she starts to move to
another room for no reason she she she's there in the living
room she moves to another room okay she's so unsafe >> I
can send her a receipt
Why is hold on listen I'm getting a I'm getting a weird vibe
from this too so give me a second let me pull back to when they
open this up okay so we go back we've got the smoking gun here
oh it's like their own edited thing that they're going to put
in here and then they're going back and forth >> I know
that's hard to to imagine like >> It's all edited together
it's all edited I was thinking okay can I see how long this this
was recorded for no I can't it's all edited together so one side
of
I want that whole recording This is not going to give you the
whole picture right he recorded this with only him recording
it this is why it's so when it's like one sided recording right
cuz he's calm right now But is he calm cuz he knows it's recorded
or And like is he getting aggressive cuz he knows it's recorded
and he knows he might need it later? And this would be before
she had ever informed anybody of something bad, but it might
not be before she recorded something. I'm not totally sure. You
notice how, by the
I think in their first stream, when Abba talked about like an
obvious indicator of of a guilty person, was it not that she
recorded something without letting him know early like before
they were fully broken up? And now we come to find out Abba recorded
something early on with no Now, I'm I'm sorry. I'm starting to
Like, by the way, this doesn't make her more innocent, okay?
This just makes him more guilty. It doesn't make her more innocent.
She's She's yelled a bunch. Bad stuff happened with her. It just
makes her more or him more guilty, in my
>> I told you you can call me again. >> Cuz I'm being
mistreated >> All right. That's not a reason to raise my
voice to me. I just want you to leave. I just want you to go.
Even said I'm not raising my voice. I just want you to leave.
And don't forget this room's empty. There's no furniture in here.
And so it echoes like crazy. Why are you staying? You're wasting
my time. I don't want you in my house no more. You want to quit?
That's it. That's a wrap between us. >> So, I can be mistreated
and then leave leave leave leave leave >> You can say you're
being mistreated. That's not a reason to raise your voice to
me. I don't really care. I don't really give a [__]
You need to go. I'm going to have to kick you out of my house,
but this has to be really 100%.
This is so performative, man. This doesn't mean what they think
it means. It's so dude, I get so um This is like black-pilling
stuff that I'm watching like a one-sided recording come out.
And again, I This could have sound like a defense of her. It's
really not. It's just you insisting that this one-sided recording
played only to your audience exonerates you of bad behavior
is absurd to me. She's done a bunch of bad behavior. I do think
she's like a bad person. She seems like she was ready to get
you from the moment she felt like slighted by you.
But I think this is the same thing and you're engaging in some
of the behaviors that you listed as negative on her end. >> And
then I'll leave my house and then I'll leave. I'm just careful
with you. >> We're not doing this back and forth on my
own [__] I'm doing that. Let's I I hotel. You can
leave. 100%. Okay, well this one called we cross paths. So, you
can either leave cuz you choose to or by holocaust. >> That's
it. >> You have to understand that he probably had some
problems with this woman, right? Also,
correct me if I'm wrong,
when did she get the abortion? It's after this, isn't it? Had
she even booked the first abortion appointment at this point?
I think she did, right?
Dude, if everything is after this
and she was pregnant,
this looks
This looks un-
to me
that this is his pregnant girlfriend
and he starts recording her when she comes back to his house.
And you can go, "Well, actually he just said it was for security."
Just for the sake Okay, but she's saying she yelled at you. She's
not saying you broke the law.
And you know you're recording so you can remain nonchalant and
not scream at her. I have no idea if you're screaming at her
before this. 3 weeks after the breakup are the abortion appointments?
The abortion appointments were before
Wait, what? Are you sure, Nix? Would you even need an abortion
appointment before
Wouldn't this be like uh like an abortion pill? Stage stage like
pre-6 weeks? >> And don't forget guys, I don't have any
obligation to. I booked the hotel. I wanted to make sure she
gets home safe. Her flight tomorrow is already set up. She has
all the information. I booked the hotel in her name, not mine.
I make sure everything is good for her. Cuz if a woman tells
me no, let me say this. If a woman ever utters the word to you,
"I don't feel safe in there, you're in crib," they got to go.
If they don't live in town, get them some >> I didn't hear
that. I Was that said in the in the audio? I didn't hear I don't
think I heard that in the audio, but I might have missed it.
"I don't feel safe." No, I asked when the abortion appointments
were made. The ones she canceled were before the trip to Montreal.
Okay, so she had canceled the appointments. Okay. Sorry. Well,
I understand that he's very upset. She's still pregnant, but
it does give me a little more context for why he's acting like
this. If he If the appointment If the appointments were booked
and canceled before this,
I would be ready to I would be like on a soapbox to like burn
this guy. >> I told you to go left. Didn't I tell you to
go left? Didn't I tell you to go left? And you're like, "We'll
see. We'll We'll see. I'm going to will see you. DO YOU NOT ALL
RIGHT, WE'RE PUTTING ON OUR SHOES WHEN WE'RE LEAVING. Now guys,
remember this next part. Cuz I'm going to have to go back cuz
you all might have forgot cuz this is a little while ago. Let
me go back. Remember what she said? What happened next? >> With
him personally, it didn't feel right. I didn't feel safe. He
would yell. He would scream. I was pregnant in Montreal. He kicked
me out. >> Think he might need to call the cops? If he
wanted safety because he was getting threatened with the police,
that is the only thing you can morally use the recording for.
He gets to tell his side of the story. He could say she's she
could say she's
He could even say I think he could even release a little bit
just say, "I recorded this. This is the tone of my Just take
back that I was lying. Explain that I was like totally this way.
Right? Or sorry, take back that I was yelling. I don't even know.
I don't think you get to record this without her knowledge, be
the calm guy the whole time, and then go "Oh yeah, I I would
cuz all I get is all the calmness in this recording is because
he knows he's recording."
And it says nothing about his conduct throughout the relationship
at all.
>> He has his reasons for it. I was pregnant. I had no
signal outside. I was locked out of the apartment in Canada >> Okay,
you guys heard that portion, right? Yeah. So I locked her out
in Canada weather, left her to die. She was going to say give
me back my keys.
I left her alone in Montreal but this recording, bro. >> I
Also, was it before or after? Was it the first time or the second
time? I I don't know, but when she told the story was it the
first time that she was locked out or the second time? It could
be the first time. I think she left on her own.
>> She says, "I'm going to take care of it. So I'm going
to get you a She says, "I'm going to take care of it." Okay.
I have text her the confirmation for the hotel. She has the pin
number I sent it to her, but she's saying, "No, I'm going to
figure it out." But she has the
No, you chose this. No, you chose this. No, you chose this. It's
not my phone doesn't work. Whatever happened to me, fine. I got
you a room. I got you a Uber. Now you're on some I'll take care
of it. My phone doesn't work. Whatever happens to me, fine. My
girl
>> Listen again.
So you know I didn't make up the subtitles. This goofy ass broad
runs outside in the middle of winter with apparently no cell
service and and and and does a damsel in distress act, which
she always does. Every time I break up with her, she's always
putting herself in danger. Don't believe me, it gets worse. So
remember I forced her out? I left her outside in Montreal weather.
She was freezing to death. I did nothing. I was going to get
her an Uber to the hotel, which was under her name. She didn't
want it. She ran outside. I'm like, "Come back." She didn't want
to.
40 feet away.
He doesn't stop running.
outside. I'm like, "You want to be [__] Go go ahead."
Watch what happens after this, okay? This next part is funny
because then I start reaching out to her to make sure she got
the information, okay?
>> Has Pearl reacted yet? I don't know. >> I have
never tried to commit because he broke up with me. >> So
this is the text message with scribbled over here.
Okay? This is the booking confirmation that I sent her, okay?
Here is her texting me after running outside like a goofball
and she goes, "My phone is going to die. I don't have service."
I'm like, "Come back to the building. I'll get you an Uber. I'm
in the lobby." I'm still trying to help this goofy ass >> Well,
you two goofies sent me. >> Fair. I'll own that. I'm being
delusional. Okay? Well, one thing I did not do is verbally and
emotionally abuse. Okay? I'll own I made plenty of mistakes.
I'll own this was a toxic relationship. Was it crazy? It wasn't
that crazy. She was definitely. But I played into it and I entertained
it for too long. But there was none of that. Everything she claimed
never happened. And I'm still trying to help her. >> I
you have not shown that at all. You've not even remotely shown
that.
man, like I'm not trying I don't
I don't like I'm not I'm not trying to cancel him. If he If dude,
if they hadn't even gotten through the abortion appointments
yet, that would be [__]
But I I honestly don't even think that I I actually like don't
think he's proven anything here. You can't one-sidedly record
something. Like it's just like when Al was freaking out over
that call, I may have like a a lot I might feel like it's a loss
of aura. I didn't even listen to it cuz it's a one-sided call.
To be honest with you, I might feel like, "Oh, you've lost some
aura that you got so emotionally disturbed." But I don't think
like her acting calm there and you screaming means you're the
abusive one in the relationship, right? >> But she But
y'all I'm saying oh you're giving me an address. I'm asking them
what location? Just text me the name. I am trying, okay? Earnestly
trying. And she also said that she would take care of it. And
now she's putting it on you. So now I get frustrated because
now I'm like no Like this is purposeful. It's been 5 hours. You're
texting me your location six times but haven't sent me an address
or the name of the store you're at. And when she texts back,
you knew this was going to happen. And I'm like oh, so you want
to argue not that you're lost or in danger. That's my status.
I'm not safe.
Man- manipulation.
>> So, I don't want to put this stuff out there. I know
she's a goofy ass person. I know she is the worst party I listen
to. I don't care. If you want to call me the worst party I am,
I'm a piece of garbage. I do whatever. But all these lies she's
doing You saw how she told the story? I kicked her outside. I
left her to die in the cold weather. I was yelling. None of it's
real. The way a lot of this other stuff is real. But a lot of
it is he said, she said. >> I man, when I when I hear her
telling that story, I do know she's lying. I'm just naturally
like oh, you're being very hyperbolic in that case. Am I just
a woman hater? Am I just like yeah, I know you're I know you're
like way over exaggerating this right now. Of course you are.
>> Because she's a pretty girl who talks calm and she recorded
me on my lowest. She can make whatever narrative. You know what?
All these red >> Dude, dude, listen to the mirror
>> But a lot of it is he said, she said. And because she's
a pretty girl who talks calm and she recorded me on my lowest.
She can make whatever >> If she's a pretty girl who talks
calm and recorded me at my lowest, and I will say I like I still
don't think I ever I get where he's coming from that he's like
had a rough time dealing with this and and he probably was emotional
in a way he never was before. I can I can understand all of that.
It's why he never should have responded at all in the first place.
In the first place, he should have basically been like no, I'm
not going to I'm not getting into it. I'm not getting into it.
I'm not getting into it. Cuz realistically, all of the people
who wanted to attack him were probably going to do so anyway
like no matter what. I just think he basically should have said
I think she's going through a rough time. I'm not going to do
anything. I'm not I'm not going to I'm not going to I'm not going
to say anything about it. Just going to let it go. >> Whatever
narrative. You know what? All lot of pill weirdos, all the ones
who say don't believe women without the >> Once you once
you bite one time, right? Once you bite one time, you are stuck
in this loop forever. Like I I knew, especially when he posted
under her video, "Oh, I'm not responding anymore. This is goofy.
We're adults. I'm not responding anymore." I'm like, yeah, you
are. Yeah, you're stuck. You're stuck. That's like Darius and
Zena, right? For all that time. That's it's just like Darius
and Zena. It's the same concept.
Right?
Oh, I'm done with that. I hate that person. I'm done with that.
Yeah, sure you are. >> Yeah, I mean you jumped on it. I
know it's just by me. I ain't even made it. Get your money. But
what happened to scrutinizing things? Y'all got to play too.
Because she sat in front of you guys and sold you a story and
you like, yeah, you know what? I could have a dude do that. Why?
Cuz at the end of the day, they don't actually care about men's
issues. They don't care about none of that [__] Don't
jump on it if it matters. And that's okay. I'm just saying. >> Dude,
I'm pretty sure I man, now for the sake of like my own for checking
myself, I want to go back and see. I I feel like
80% chance I sort of let it go by and didn't really respond.
I feel like there's a 10% chance, maybe a 18% chance, that I
heard her say like lock me out in the cold and I'm like, nah,
I don't think so. I'm pretty sure I did, man. >> You got
their moving, not mine. It's all these people that I was talking
about, but don't believe all women. And then they believe the
one that he said >> Like what is this? And where's the
abuse? I'm sorry. My [__] I'm being abused. DO YOU
GUYS KNOW WHAT CRAZY this story is? This woman has been [__]
with me and blackmailing me. And I got people actually >> I
do think she he's like I I don't know if I can man, it's hard
for me to call it abuse when
I will say okay, I couple things. Re-figuring
the timeline, when he does freak out on her, he probably has
reason to think she's still [__] with him. He may
be aware of these things, right? Like the three email and stuff,
and she was [__] with him a little sooner than he
thought. And I have a hard time calling it abuse. Some of this
stuff is absolutely abusive. The text with the Myron Gaines message
like laid out, that's abusive. That's like totally abusive. That
is saying, "I'm going to go to your biggest enemy, and I'm going
to reveal all your
That's like psychotic to me. You don't do that to anybody you've
ever had anything major with.
Right? I I just think that to me, that's like a that's just a
massive like that's not a red flag, that's like a oh do not ever
interact with this person again. >> She hit me up as if
I'm >> So, anyway, I just I don't want to minimize what
he's going through, cuz he is going through a lot. I just think
man, he's an emotional guy. >> the person who was involved
Imagine parenting with someone this in
I just yeah. I just hope you guys understand. I can tolerate
a lot. Her harassing me all day, I don't care. It's the fact
that she's contacting the people around me. That's what's difficult.
It's the fact that she's forcing this into the public eye, and
then revealing details about my personal life that I only shared
with her intimately. These are not necessary. What What hobbies
does Abby like? What does he like? >> Uh this is this is
a lot. The That That's when I totally flipped on her, the fact
that she was able willing to go do an interview with um the saint
man, the the saint in the center. That's >> You're like,
"Why do you want to podcast discussing what I like?"
What's that about? And that's like the weird vindictive nature
like I've never had an ex who I've gone after. I've never had
an ex who we had large issues like nothing. Almost all my exes
I'm on amicable terms with. I'm like, "Dude, you're good. I'm
good. I'm just wishing you well." I don't but I could cuz we
used to Only this person Well, I wouldn't even consider a relationship.
It was a joke. But now it's for the internet to go look at and
examine every text message and every fight. It's like I want
to leave this in the past, and she wouldn't let it go. And she's
so crazy that even though she's the wrong party in a lot of these
scenarios, and she's lying flat >> execution. It's kind
of weird, but still clearly the woman got uh some screws loose.
Well, they both got some screws
Yeah. Yeah, I agree with you. I would say she like from what
I could tell, man, I want to say she it seems like she's kind
of the impetus. It might be that they mixed bad. I don't know
exactly what it is cuz man, I've seen some major red flags from
him right now. Like some totally crazy red flags. It might just
be that he was with people who were compatible and and didn't
like freak out over some of the things he did. That could be
more what it is. He's got some major red flags, too.
I think by virtue of him not chasing stuff down, like by virtue
of him Oh man. OH, I SAY THAT then I'm like, "Dude, how did he
find the Instagram? How did he find the Instagram? Why did he
freak out and call her a cheater over the
I think he Sorry, I'm trying to figure out how to get this just
right. I do think he's the more wronged party.
But he is the impetus for his own destruction or his own like
this coming up to the public, which is bad. Yeah. Yeah. The Yeah,
she pretty crazy. She's the crazier one. That's hard for me to
say. I don't like saying that.
I I just don't like saying that cuz usually when I get this performance,
it's like the woman was not necessarily like the major contributor,
like like
It could be in this case, which is a little different. When when
you get this this pageantry, I find it's usually to hide like
gaps in the story. And that's the case here, but it's gaps that
are embarrassing, maybe not gaps that are >> But this is
stupid. And now you're over here talking about my personal You
know, this ever like getting pegged? Actually, no, he never did
that. Like why are you talking about my life? You want to talk
about it? We can talk about This girl's too fused. She's got
a Christian complex. >> Dude, he's going to start He's
going to start dumping all of her fetishes and Uh this is not
good. Uh this is not good. He's actually evil? Mm, I don't think
it's evil. I think he feels like she went on and she was willing
to comment on his [__] So, she's going to come back
at him in the other direction or he's going to come back at her
in the other direction. I do think this is where I hope this
is where he's like, "Just kidding. Of course I wouldn't do that
cuz I'm an adult and I would never do that to another person."
>> And it turns out in bed she's a giant heathens and a
freak weirdo, okay? Now me, my partner likes weird. I don't like
Why? Because as long as you're within the boundaries of what's
okay to me, I'll do that for her. I'm a pretty vanilla guy on
the day, but not this >> Okay. Uh-huh, stop the cap, bro.
Stop the cap.
>> So, we won't put it all out there. I wouldn't do it.
Right, she's like some some good Christian girl who pretends
like, "Oh, I'm such a petite petite like whatever." This girl
likes a dog collar on her neck and she likes to >> Okay,
so pet play stuff. Okay, okay, okay. Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay. All right, okay. Okay, okay.
>> And one of the reasons when we ended things that she
wanted to get back together, she was worried that she would never
meet anyone who'd want to enjoy because none of her other exes
would entertain putting a dog collar on her and walking around
like a good old
Now, hold on. Hold on.
How do I What's appropriate for this? That's an obvious lie.
That's Oh, hold >> anyone who'd want to enjoy because none
of her other exes would entertain putting a dog collar on her
and walking around like a good old [__]
>> That's crazy.
So, listen. Listen.
I don't believe that.
I don't believe that. Does anybody believe that? I don't think
a single person
believes that. Are you dumb enough to believe that, Aba? Please,
Preach. Please, just say what everybody's thinking. Be real.
Be be for real right now, Preach.
>> Yo, chat. Put some air head in the chat if you hear
me. Now, look. I never owned a pet, but I didn't mind putting
a collar on her. It was fine. You know what I mean? She just
wasn't allowed to pee on my floor and she knew how to follow
the rules, okay? This is what she's into. I don't mind. One of
the points of contention One of the points of contention between
us was the fact that >> Bro, I I can't help but think this
is a massive mistake. I'm sorry.
I can't help but think this is like a huge mistake.
Oh, boy. Yeah. Oh, boy.
This This is not good. What I know he's into some weird too.
>> that she was way more freaky and she was worried that
that's going to be an issue. I'm going to put your business out
there. You know what I'm saying? >> You want to Oh, wait.
Does it keep >> My business out there we can do that. Right?
She was worried. She was worried that she's more freaky than
me. I don't mind. Little Asian girls I'm so polite. The dog collar,
okay? That's what she's into. You want to put my business out
there? I'll put your business out there, too. This She likes
dirty talking a lot. Likes weird [__] I don't mind,
okay? Yes, my penis is big. It is what it
>> You pushed it there, my girl. You pushed it there. The
thing is Aba's not even like that. Putting [__] out
there. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on.
Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Yeah, you go hit her up. When you
see her next time. Hold on. When am I going to see her?
I was not the one to put out filth like that. Very private.
>> You're doing it right now. The first chance, the first
time he ever would have needed to do it, he's putting it all
out there. What What do you mean?
>> You pushed him to that. Do you understand what I'm saying?
You went around You go around and you talk people to the people's
business. You got to vent around and parading in some kind of
bootoo shoes Christian
And then you don't expect retaliation from people. >> Yeah,
oh, this is so broken. This thought process is so broken.
Bro, Christian people are so [__] Like there's Why
are they pretending they don't understand this concept of like
the inverse correlation between like repression as a youth versus
what you're into as adult?
I I feel like this is like if it's not a confirmed like studied
phenomenon, it's like an accepted trope, right? We'll see. >> My
girl. I'm not even mad. I wish it hadn't come to that, but god
damn. When you push someone, you push someone.
I'm [laughter] not even I'm not even I'm not I I don't even agree
with all this, but I could see I put myself in that position
and you put all my [__] out I don't know how I'm
going to be any different. I'm going to I'm not going to be like
you and be like, well, I'm I'm the better person. Look at this
message. She's like, I'm shaking. I'm whatever. I'm going to
quit my job. It's like everything was a crisis with this person.
She was never put together. I'm in the hospital >> Sorry.
I'm sorry. I did I did kind of laugh at the end. Oh, man. Uh
I'm panicking. Please tell me. Please talk to me. Please please
please. You're a clown. Clown face.
Uh please answer. I'm panicking. Abba, I quit my job because
of this breakup. I'm moving back home. How much did it hit me?
I told you the new IG on the phone. It's all just a cope. Do
you remember me telling So, this is when he told her she was
a cheating loser or whatever, right? This is when he was having
that freak out. Abba doesn't understand that he's doing the same
thing back to her and and gendering the same response from her
that he had that he was willing to deal with like really bad
happening to him because of how like upset and emotional she
was and he would implicitly like take it as oh I did something
wrong and sort of try to try to make it right and he's doing
the same thing back to her when he accuses her of cheating with
the Instagram and she's like oh my god please talk to me please
talk to me. >> Collected the data, we know what you are,
you're not a good person, it's been triple quadruple verified,
she's a >> A few moments later.
>> Hi there. >> That's crazy.
>> Like imagine being this much of a loser where people
talk about you like you're a dog and you're so desperate to get
some clout that you're willing to do these interviews. >> Yeah,
that's that's like first base for her Abba. Were you not paying
any attention during your relationship?
Were you not paying any attention at
>> And this is what we're honestly dealing with but I'm
going to go to the loose you know loose portion here because
like all this is really stupid to me. I go back to the same thing
that we had a discussion about earlier which is why is all this
really happening?
And it comes back to what I >> But I did everything right.
I did everything right Abba and you know >> And you know
what's been the most vindicating thing about this whole thing
about this whole relationship for me? I knew it was weird and
[__] up but I moved on. But it's been funny seeing
random people, people who don't like me examine her behavior.
People who didn't watch my content, don't like me or whatever
it could be and they see her behavior and they see her behavior
for what it is. Even for
>> Dude, all so many of these people
Bro, Abba is because he's the big creator with like some clout
right now. Uh there's two things going on. One, none of the red
pill people can take the side of a woman. That's like sacrilege,
they cannot do that, right?
And then
and then
we haven't even listened to this full audio. I don't want to
listen to that full audio because I'm like it's a one-sided conversation,
it's missing part of it and like I don't hear the start, I don't
hear how and I can hear her like baiting baiting him into stuff
the same way I could hear him being like calm, cool, collected
when he's recording one-sidedly, right? It's like the mirror
image of each other.
I just think
she might be a psycho but Alba's behavior has to be like an analyzed
here, okay? It has to be analyzed cuz weird. >> If you
broke up with him, why are you calling him 3 hours later? Bueller?
Anybody can help me understand that? Bueller? So in other words,
you weren't really done. It's a manipulation. It is a game. You
broke up with him and like I'm done [laughter] with you. I'm
done with you. I'm done with you. 3 hours Hey, let's talk. WHAT
IS THERE TO TALK ABOUT? WHAT IS THERE TO TALK ABOUT? 3 hours
later, it is a game. >> You know what? In a few months
you're going to understand that I did everything right. >> In
a few months you're going to understand that I did everything
right. She is so perfect around here.
She is so perfect around here. She does everything right. He
needs to listen to her. I'm going to tell you. I just want to
Help me understand. Why did you He's so mean. How could he say
these things to me? Girl, another one. It don't matter. Tether
or American, it don't dag on matter. She with her calmness like
>> And keep in mind, this call is right after she ended
things and she told me she was keeping the baby. The one where
she's super wrong, she admits herself. The one where she just
blew up and betrayed me in a big way. And within a short time
span she's on the phone and she wants to like talk calm after
everything, okay? And that's why she >> I never knew she
was recording this. >> What she needs is full compliance
and agreeance on perspective.
>> Oh, hold on. If this is the first time Now, I don't
know the timeline.
Now, I don't know the timeline. >> Until you fully agree
with what happened in the facts and the details the way she sees
it, she will not move on. >> And that was my entire experience
with this woman. And that's why she's online right now doing
all this goofy ass It's because she needs the whole internet
to agree with her. She will not stop. She will keep going.
So, what do I think about this whole situation? All in all I
just want everybody to move on. I don't want to talk about my
personal business. I don't want to put it on Front Street. I
don't want to talk about the other side of things. I don't want
to talk about kid nothing. I've always believed that this woman
was manipulating and using the child as a way to control me.
And you guys saw the many ways in which she did so throughout
the relationship. But also, if she wanted the kid so bad, how
come when I was out of the picture, she killed it? She never
wanted that child. Once she realized she couldn't use it to control
that's what happened. And then what she do after that, even though
I'm so verbally abusive and I was the reason everything ended,
she tried to get back with me. She tried to move to Montreal
to live with me. Do you understand how crazy this is? Go ahead.
And on the the other lie that we did, you didn't want to mention
that. You didn't want to mention that. You're like, I know. I
know. I just know. But
we don't. And I know a lot of us are still asking ourselves,
you know she lies so much and she lies to that extent. Like,
you had to prove all that [__] and you had to go
through all that that you had to prove. Recording [clears throat]
her, recording her when she was feeling unsafe and everything
and stuff. Then I still question the pregnancy. I know you're
not and you're like, no, she was whatever whatever and you guys
have your reasons. I'm not even I don't want you to put your
[__] out there. You're you're the one that's going
to be
I and I can always can al- al- al- always be like, hey, if she
lies that much with everything she's talking about to that extent,
she wants to keep you out of the pregnancy. She She wants to
keep you out of the pregnancy. She wants to keep you out of the
of the abortion. She wants to keep you out of all of that. >> But
she wouldn't lie about that. There's still that to question.
That.
That that's that's >> Okay, that that that that that. >> a
weird one to me still to this day. I'm like, yo, I think she
was lying about that, too. I think she was She's She's a demon
enough to do that. I've seen these demons. Yeah. >> I'm
like, I'm pretty excited, to be honest. This is all fine. This
is like, okay, I got this. I think Abba I don't think he exonerated
himself. He certainly
he made her look worse in some place. I'm trying to think of
what I didn't pick up that she looks worse on.
No, I don't know if I Man, I had a really bad opinion of her
after the Marquette Brown uh Marquette Burton Burton, the Saint
center guy. I had a horrible impression of her after that.
I don't know that this has changed much at all.